with Captain Marvel fresh off its box
office conquering opening weekend Marvel
is already thinking ahead to its next
blockbuster I like this one
having disrupt the official trailer for
the superhero in feuds crossover event
of the year
the New Avengers endgame clip is clearly
built to stoke fan anticipation every
moment seemed to have something
important to say and comes with a
potential of deeper meanings hidden
explanations and misleading directions
let's break it down and take a look at
the details you might have missed and
the newest Avengers endgame trailer and
just so we're all clear potential and
rumored spoilers ahead don't say we
didn't warn you we've seen this before
the Avengers and game Super Bowl spots
opened on a quick sequence I've sped
through 10 MCU characters most of whom
had died or been snapped in infinity war
everything was in black white and red
all over this time around the red
highlighted footage is back and also
specifically highlights some different
faces like Tony Stark Steve Rogers Thor
and acai a four characters who did not
get snapped it's pretty widely known
that Avengers and game as a final movie
and Chris Hemsworth Robert Downey jr.
and Chris Evans Marvel studio contracts
that doesn't mean they're definitively
done with their characters but if you're
gonna retire a role you could do worse
and saving half the universe you know
meanwhile all that red coloring still
seems highly symbolic red is often
connected to blood and death but as
we've theorized before it could have
something to do with the red reality
stone and as possible usage in
unsnapping the world will that Jen be
instrumental in defeating Thanos once
and for all if this montage means what
we think it might keep your eyes peeled
for that scarlet stone one of the most
exciting moments in the first trailer
was the arrival of Scott Lang that the
Avengers HQ with his quantum powered
ant-man
while the presence of Langan endgame is
a pleasant if not a particularly
surprising revelation one
attention-getting moment occurred when
Captain Black Widow asked each other
about what they're seeing just an old
message
no you know that many detail-oriented
fans are seized on her not quite answer
to suggest that the footage wasn't
actually live the word archive in the
upper left corner of the screen also led
some to theorize that perhaps the
security camera clip was in fact a very
old message and from a different year in
tile a in the new trailer things seem to
point toward a postnup arrival for langa
ant-man features heavily throughout the
trailer but one scene in particular
shows a befuddled scarce looking at a
telephone pole plastered with missing
person posters while this could be
highlighting a particularly active day
for kidnappers
chances are the scene puts Lang firmly
after the snap as he starts to piece
together what happened one of the
biggest questions that swirled since the
dust from infinity war settled was if
how and when time travel would factor
into avengers endgame ant-man and the
wasp explored the potential of the
quantum realm opening up the opportunity
for that mode of interdimensional
transportation to come into play in
endgame and we know from that film's
post-credit scene that the quantum realm
is entangled with time-travel in some
way and don't get sucked into a time
vortex we won't be able to save you and
as this newest trailer seems to indicate
it appears more and more likely that
audiences will be pulled around the MCU
timeline in endgame a Super Bowl spot
showed clips of Liberty island
surrounded by apparently abandoned ships
as well as citi field looking ominously
abandoned and not just because the Mets
missed the playoffs again the Statue of
Liberty showed up for a second time in
the new trailer but so did another more
interesting clip halfway through the
trailer we see a short sequence of the
Avengers quinjets coming out of the
clouds with a city in front of them
except this time the buildings are all
lit up could they be celebrating getting
the power grid back on post decimation
or are we witnessing a heroic crew
heading back to the past a quick shot in
the trailer shows a very angry nebula
whipping Elsa's swords and making a run
at an unseen foe Papa Thanos perhaps the
likelihood of nebula playing a key role
in the film is high especially
considering her crucial part in the
original Infinity Gauntlet comics event
but another interesting thing to notice
about the scene as a landscape behind
her the scenery is quite a mess of fire
and flame and even a little reminiscent
of the battle on Titan from infinity war
of
course at the end of the previous
Avengers movie we're not quite sure
where fun ascends up some have suggested
that his new home could be anywhere from
within the soul stone to Wakanda itself
however reports surfaced online that
Disney shareholders were allegedly shown
a clip that put the kibosh on either of
those two theories one more time for
anyone who wasn't paying attention
earlier spoiler alert
still here in the clip nebula reportedly
say she knows where Thanos is and
coupled with an energy signature has
been picked up out in space heads off to
find him
cut this clip of nebula on a battle Tron
planet actually take place on the long
rumored Titan 2 that Thanos withdrew to
after his work was done one of the most
glaring things missing from an affinity
war was he anxiously anticipated reunion
between Tony Stark and Steve Rogers
while the two leaders are technically
buried the hatchet thanks to Steve's
letter and accompanying emergency cell
phone bruised egos and her feelings take
a while to heal of course a Thanos level
apocalypse goes a long way to what
helping a reconciliation occur and it's
hard not to believe that once cap and
Iron Man got into the same room together
they'll be able to figure things out one
way or another
the bigger question at this point is
what in the world or off of the world
that meeting will take place well the
new trailer doesn't show the first scene
where they set eyes on each other we do
a long lasting a glimpse of the two
brothers in arms to suit it up walking
side-by-side and man does it feel good
and on that note what are those special
suits for anyway
quantum exploration time travel both
well regardless with Iron Man and
Captain Alita gather again the world
feels a little just a little bit safer
unless this trailer is another misdirect
like when Marvel revealed an infinity
war trailer showing Hulk running
alongside the Avengers in Wakanda which
was a scene that never happened in the
film they wouldn't do that to us again
would they would they check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]